Translator: Joseph Geni
Reviewer: Morton Bast
(Music by Anna Oxygen)
(Music: "Shells" by Mirah)
♪ You learned how to be a diver ♪
♪ Put on a mask and believe ♪
♪ Gather a dinner of shells for me ♪
♪ Take the tank down so you can breathe ♪
♪ Below ♪
♪ Movements slow ♪
♪ You are an island ♪
♪ All the secrets until then ♪
♪ Pried open I held them ♪
♪ Until they were still ♪
(Music)
(Music by Caroline Lufkin)
(Music by Anna Oxygen)
♪ Dream time, I will find you ♪
♪ You are shady, you are new ♪
♪ I'm not so good at mornings ♪
♪ I can see too clearly ♪
♪ I prefer the nighttime ♪
♪ Dark and blurry ♪
♪ Falling night ♪
♪ Hovering light ♪
♪ Calling night ♪
♪ In the moontime I will give up my life ♪
♪ And in the deep dreams ♪
♪ You will find me ♪
(Applause)
[Excerpts from "Myth and Infrastructure"]
Bruno Giussani: Come back.
Miwa Matreyek!
(Applause)